so in commercial fiction like gone girl
they changed it significantly to make it
more of a thriller in them in the book
version Ben Affleck snot who he is in
the cinematic version and the the woman
isn't either in in the in the movie the
woman is a super villain she's and and
Ben Affleck is this tragic hero who at
the BMOC points is asked to change to
step up to rescue her and to sort of
assert his manhood and in the movie he
fails to do this at all the points of
the BMOC he just doesn't and in the end
she wins she manipulates him so much
that when she gets out of that car all
bloody and embraces him I'm in front of
the press he just says you
but he doesn't challenge it in fact her
version of the whole thing becomes
accepted and he's going to be stuck for
the next 20 years living with the
monster right now you probably imagine
what's gonna happen she's probably gonna
kill him in a year or two but that's the
end of the movie now the book doesn't do
that so we teach these genre tools so
when you converting a literary book into
a Hollywood movie you use the same genre
tools that you use if you were buying a
script from a dope fiend kid in
Hollywood you you it's a commercial art
form and the way I say that it is you
know a vanity license plate in
California of a lot you've got seven
letters and to make something funny or
something good and that's a commercial
art form you have a frame and you've got
to fit your story into this frame in
fact that's the the delight is to see
that it fits into this frame for
instance if you had okay you got seven
letters so I saw a Corvette last year
and the vanity plate said three inches
right so that's funny right this guy is
a small penis now if you had 30 letters
or 300 letters to make this same point
it wouldn't be funny right so it a
commercial art form like a Hollywood
movie or Hollywood television show is a
frame you have to learn to fit your
letters into in a way that makes it
delightful for the audience the cool
part is television has kind of expanded
that frame and and you can do more
unusual stuff in television but movies I
think we had just as many movies made
last year as ever movies also have
extraordinary power and they're not
going to go away movies aren't aren't
dying I mean people Minh said they're
dying since the 20s they're still here
because but but what's interesting to me
is that television now tells stories in
10 minute little sequence beats and
that's about our attention span when
we're watch when we're on on our
computers I'll even watch a television
show like breaking bad for 10 minutes
and then I'll turn it off and I'll go
surfer I'll do something else I'll come
back and watch another 10 minute piece
and then I'll go serve a news and I even
watch movies a lot like that now our
attention span is getting shorter and
shorter and televisions sort of fits
that bite-sized storytelling Sensibility
almost better than movies we sometimes
now sort of get sort of distracted if
we're sitting here watching a movie for
an hour and a half so you always want to
construct your movies in these little
eight or nine minute sequences anyway
but television is sort of supercharged
that and we now can watch TV for a few
minutes and then go watch something else
and then come back to it but books are
always gonna make fabulous movies
because the characterization level in a
book is usually much deeper and stronger
than in a screenplay there's more time
to describe the person
there's more situations there's more
depth to that book characterization then
there was to a movie script movie
scripts tend to scan on that
characterization
you